welcome everyone
[Music]
welcome back to meme review it's been so
long dude
but we finally have some quality memes
i think what you'll find in today's
episode is that all the memes
are deeply in intertwined they're deeply
connected
let's start off with the most despicable
news
i have ever heard in my entire life they
changed lola the bunny from uh space jam
apparently they're making a space jam
too
this is what lola used to look like and
this is her now
what the [ __ ] happened to lola did she
attract some terminal
illness what is wrong with her where are
the thighs
where are the [ __ ] voice space jam
director reworks lola bunny for reboot
from sexualized to strong is that what
they did to
sonic the hedgehog from sexualized to
strong
this is the result change it change it
back right now
i hate to split hairs here get it but
listen desexualizing lola bunny by
giving her more standard athletic gear
that's a choice that's a choice that's a
[ __ ] choice
but you can't tell me you can't that the
lola on the right appears stronger or
more capable than the lola on the left
yeah that's what i thought when i saw
the lola on the left she's stronger and
more capable
am i am i missing something here was
everyone jerking off to the low-lying
space jam what is happening
who gives a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
it's a bunny regardless you understand
this
am i the only one with this [ __ ]
opinion hey all this [ __ ] horny
how am i supposed to enjoy a movie about
basketball with no big bubba
i don't know i i enjoyed it what the
[ __ ]
i don't even remember lola being high
you know the remake is going to suck
anyway space jam was such a such a
perfect encapsulated moment of 90s
what the [ __ ] are they gonna do now
right cool they encapsulated how we all
have to stay home epic can't wait to
watch that
okay so apparently that the one everyone
is uh
a bonky for it's the fan art it's a
[ __ ] fan art
these are screenshots from the action
movie that's taken from the from my
favorite
cartoon animation arcade website all
right well she is kinda
all right i get it all right i kind of
get it she has the sexual nature to her
i understand i get it now gamers
i understand why you're so outraged well
the horny winders actually have a point
this time
[Laughter]
yeah she looks [ __ ] dumb i i kind of
get it but also who [ __ ] cares too
jesus christ
hey if i learned something over these
past years on the internet
you complain about it enough and
eventually you get your way
so let's see if the internet can pitch
their way back for lola
am i the only one having a problem with
the thighs i mean look
the [ __ ] are these the hell is that [ __ ]
i need some thighs damn son
that's some thick ass thighs that's what
i'm talking about
hell yeah we're listening oh this just
in
warner brothers have made the response
we're listening
we are pleased to announce that we'll be
giving bugs bunny an absolute
absolutely throbbing polish in the next
space jam
can't wait
so glad to see a company that listens to
their fans
okay upgrade upgrade [ __ ] go back
i don't know man handle my heart
swear to god i would prefer thick
i would prefer this version then this
[ __ ] on the right
because then i would go haha big chunks
big luggers that's hilarious lola meme
gets a four
there you go well i don't get it i don't
really get it i'm not gonna lie
furry [ __ ] has never done anything for
me so i will never do anything back
however next meme
this is some really important now we're
really
getting into it mom the food is not that
high
the food this is a still image from the
movie big hero 6.
and i haven't seen that movie and i
don't remember boba's
i don't remember booboo guys uh just
realized i got to watch big hero 6.
i'll be right back
[Music]
it was all alike there's no bubbles
behold the truth ah
it hurt it hurt why it hurt it was never
real from the beginning
so why it still feel pain
reality photoshop say it thanos say the
line thanos
now dude this is [ __ ] this is some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you i'm from man lola
okay fine this is blatant censorship
that never occurred but it still feels
like censorship
okay okay okay we were so close to
victory
we were so close finally after all these
years
i have them buff why
i don't know i shouldn't be surprised
the internet is horny who would have
thought
on cash scrolling through reddit
watching her memes would be like
yeah i'm sorry anne cass i don't i guess
there's no harm in a fictional character
being sexualized
right it's time to go what's that good
babe
you're going to horny jail you're going
to horny jail
if you locked up on cats bubba memes
you're going to horny jail hand over
your horny badge
[ __ ] you hot twin sisters working at the
burger king i work at
me trying to resist noticing their
double whoppers the [ __ ] is this this is
so bad dude
what the hell hot girl from school that
has an only fans nobody knows about
nobody
people have only fans in school now
jesus christ dude
look at what they turned me into those
perverts
that's nothing i used to be a nine-foot
male dinosaur turtle
and i used to be a planet yeah this
really puts it in context doesn't it the
internet is a weird [ __ ] place
and yeah this reminds me of the resident
evil 6 big bubba waifu
right
so we finally
what is it resident evil live eight
which one are we on right now
seven it's kind of interesting though
how like
they announced this huge titty villain
in in uh
in a game and it's like bravo it's
getting all this kind of press and
attention
and marketing and then they announced
the complete opposite
in space jam and it says
this [ __ ] sucks how is it supposed to
be a horror game if this is what's out
there trying to kill me
am i missing something here resident
evil huh
neighbors in print neighbors in real
life god
damn that's a thick boy it shows me we
just need
an early no not november this year no
not march
march towards no not how about that
the [ __ ] this days every meme is
sex related this is brilliant but i like
this
redditers like right now this is cool
but i like your big titties i like big
bubba
that's hot you're all going to horny
jail you understand
who's laughing then you will see no
titty in horny jail
no thick resident evil mom no thick
aunties
but at least you won't get to see the
lola remake
at least they don't get to see the
lowland remake
hi hey oh look at my little college mate
i never felt so lied to by something
that was never a lie to begin with
it's awful it's even worse somehow isn't
it
alright next meme epic
oh [ __ ]
everywhere i go i see his face
[Music]
among us memes in 2021 everyone i keep
seeing among us such get out of my head
get out of my head
everywhere i look i keep seeing a
monkeys
q humongous there's no escape
i keep seeing him oh god
it's everywhere oh god
among us has always been such holy sh
oh my god ah instagram
what the [ __ ] is going so fast
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
oh
whoa what the [ __ ] dude champions
[Music]
god it's all one big conspiracy
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my [ __ ] god dude oh my [ __ ] god
i'm losing my mind
it never i can't look at my toes anymore
oh [ __ ] oh god
[Music]
oh it keeps going
[ __ ] they're everywhere they're [ __ ]
everywhere oh not the toes again please
all right that was it for this week's
meme review
i rate them all zero thank you for
watching
smash like subscribe see you tomorrow
breakfast